Herzinfarkte mit hilfe künstlicher nano-partikel
vorhersagen depression mit software behandeln und hautkrebs durch algorithmen
diagnostizieren das alles ist nicht das drehbuch für einen neuen science-fiction-film
sondern die ziele von großen tech firmen wie microsoft facebook amazon apple und google denn die sind fest davon überzeugt
Das verständnis von krankheiten sei letztendlich ein daten problem das gelöst werden muss wie das
Genau funktionieren soll und ob das nicht nur die medizin sondern tatsächlich unsere komplette welt schon bald auf den kopf stellt
jetzt in science fiction herzlich willkommen
Die forschungs hauptquartier von microsoft geht es schon länger nicht mehr um windows oder wird es geht. Um behandlung und heilung von tumorpatienten
Doch es wird nicht direkt an patienten und patientinnen geforscht sondern beispielsweise einen dreidimensionalen
computertomografie
darstellung das ziel den krebs besiegen oder ihn zumindest eindämmen und vernünftig behandeln
zu können sehr viel personal spezialisiert auf medizinische informatik aber vor allem unzählige server arbeiten an diesem ziel
Die beteiligten sind sie sicher da findet gerade eine riesige revolution
Im medizinbereich stadt und die treibenden kräfte dabei sind der technische fortschritt und die digitalisierung tech giganten wie amazon apple
Google, oder facebook
investieren in neues personal aus den bereichen biologie
medizin und chemie und öffnen komplett neue abteilungen zusammen mit software experten und expertinnen sollen sie die große
rechenaufgabe lösen die rechenaufgabe deren ergebnis
Am ende die biologie entschlüsselt und uns krankheiten von grund auf verstehen lässt die medizinische
datenverarbeitung dient als grundpfeiler dieser logik die instrumente
künstliche intelligenz und die analyse und auswertung riesiger datenmengen innerhalb kürzester zeit das ergebnis
zellfunktionen verstehen genome also die dna
Kostengünstig sequenzieren und neue medikamente entwickeln in der medizinischen grundlagenforschung, im bereich geht es aber auch
um grundsätzliche fragen wie wie können patienten informationen wie puls insulin oder blutwerte
kontinuierlich analysiert werden und wie können solche risiken mengen an
Patienteninformationen maschinell ausgewertet werden hier ein paar konkrete beispiele aus der praxis bei amazon geht es hauptsächlich um virtuelle
arztbesuche und darum wie sich riesige datenmengen
im medizinischen bereich in einer cloud speichern lassen mark zuckerberg der facebook gründer unterstützt ein forschungszentrum das einen
menschlichen zelle atlas aufbauen soll google möchte mit hilfe von software depressionen heilen und herzinfarkte mit hilfe künstlicher
nano-partikel
voraussagen wow das klingt wirklich irre und das alles läuft tatsächlich wie geschmiert denn die rahmenbedingungen in den usa
Sind optimal das amerikanische gesundheitssystem
boomt mehr als 20 prozent der staatsausgaben fließen in diese branche
Zudem ist es für die tech firmen nicht schwer ihre innovationen unter die leute zu bringen die fdp. Also die amerikanische arzneimittelzulassungsbehörde
Hat erst vor kurzem das prozedere beschleunigt durch das technik medizin produkte überhaupt für den markt zugelassen werden dass alles
basiert auf den fortschritten im bereich der künstlichen intelligenz und die sind nach meinung vieler experten und experten innerhalb kürzester zeit regelrecht
Explodiert mittlerweile ist es gar nicht mehr nötig software zu entwickeln
stattdessen entwickeln sie sich selbst da sie aus daten lernt und genau das wollen sich die
forschungsabteilung zunutze machen sowie microsoft in seinem projekt
Hannover ihre idee computer könnten für jeden einzelnen patienten jede einzelne patienten individuell angepasst den
medikamenten cocktails finden statt einen wirkstoff nach dem anderen zu testen könnte intelligente software auf grundlage
der genomischen daten der patienten die literatur nach der perfekten medikamentenkombination durchsuchen auf einen schlag können
So tausende von kombinationen analysiert werden und dem ärzte-team
vorgeschlagen werden durch die zusammenarbeit mit dem menschen könnten die maschinen dann sogar immer weiter dazulernen und ihre intelligenz
ausbauen so etwas ähnliches
derzeit wird das bereits in einem pilotprojekt in eugen getestet und zwar
Am night cancer institute for microsoft künstliche intelligenz also
Entscheidungshilfe als eine art arzthelfer mit schier unendlichem wissen und das ist nicht das einzige projekt das hoffnung macht ibm
eine ki entwickelt die die dna sequenzierung eines gehirntumors schneller und zuverlässiger
analysiert hat als das gesamte team von experten in israel arbeitet ein forschungsteam an einem virtuellen
gesundheits assistenten der die patienten und patientinnen
Im chat berät die maschine hat zugriff auf eine riesige datenbank und alle
aufnahme protokolle bei wunsch zudem auf die persönlichen daten der patienten
Auch wenn es immer wieder kritik an dieser
datensammelei gibt in diesen fällen ist das nicht nur äußerst sinnvoll sondern bildet tatsächlich die basis für diese art von forschung die gefahr allerdings bleibt
Was passiert wenn konten gehackt und fremde vollen zugriff auf die gesamten persönlichen wirklich intimen daten?
Von patientinnen bekommen abgesehen von einem hacker-angriff wer genau hat zugriff auf die daten krankenkassen etwa die so viel mehr
Über, ihre mitglieder erfahren als diesen vielleicht lieb es doch
Genau das ist der spagat nur wenn die maschinen vollen zugriff auf möglichst viele daten haben können sie funktionieren die frage also
Lohnte sich dafür alle seine daten herzugeben eine große vision der tech firmen ist es übrigens auch die menschlichen biologie
Irgendwann einmal so steuern zu können wie eine software dna könnte dann beispielsweise
programmiert werden ebenso wie zellen dies ist einem forschungsteam der stanford university tatsächlich schon gelungen und soll nun weiter
Perfektioniert werden dazu muss man verstehen wie sie funktionieren denn so die idee ließe sich eine programmiersprache
Erfinden um ihre steuerung zu übernehmen krebs in einer zelle ließ sie sich so also erkennen und der
molekulare computer könnte in diesem fall das kommando
selbstmord befehl
Natürlich nur für die krebszellen wenn ihr kein video zum thema und auch
Zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird mir her ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann verpasst er kein video hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
Bedroht künstliche intelligenz die menschheit mit den gefahren die von ki ausgehen ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran